north korea has built up a reputation
for being one of the strictest and the
most rigid countries in the world from
their tight control on immigration to
their unforgiving labor camps it's no
question that north korea is not messing
around one of the most notable aspects
of north korea has been their missile
and rocket development effort the media
has been pointing to this as being a
major threat for decades now and the
leaders around the world have
consistently tried to get north korea to
denuclearize as the world powers move
into space and create things like the us
space force however will north korea be
able to keep up or is nuclear technology
their last hurrah
well here's everything we know about
north korea's elusive space agency
taking a look back north korea did not
establish a space program for quite some
time after world war ii
it wasn't until the 1980s that north
korea created the korean committee of
space technology or the kcst
the kcst was originally responsible for
everything related to the country's
space effort from designing new
satellites to developing launch
technology
the organization's first step though was
building a launch facility
in the early 1980s the kcst built the
tonke satellite launching ground in the
north hamgyong province the construction
effort wasn't super organized though the
north koreans built the launch facility
on and off throughout the 1980s and
1990s by 1985 they completed
construction of their launch pad but
aside from that they didn't have much to
show after years of construction they
simply had a rudimentary command bunker
a radar facility and a few storage and
support buildings the initial goal was
to just reverse engineer the soviet
squad rocket and produce their own
copies
so the rudimentary infrastructure was
enough for the time being
throughout the 1990s however the north
koreans would significantly expand this
facility
reports suggest that the site grew from
just two kilometers in length to nine
kilometers in length
the new additions included a missile
assembly facility a fuel storage
facility a guidance and range control
center and a tracking facilities as the
tonka satellite launching ground was
finished up the north koreans shifted
their effort to building a new launching
set called the sohe satellite launching
station construction began in the early
1990s but like the tonke site
construction would stretch out for quite
some time
it wasn't until 2011 that the site was
completed
the north koreans did get a lot of work
done though as the base ended up being
six square kilometers which is five
times larger than the tonghay site aside
from being much larger the sohe site was
also far more advanced and included
elements such as a static rocket motor
test stand and a much more substantial
mission control center instead of the
command bunker they used to use
in terms of actual missions and space
programs the north koreans have only had
three substantial programs thus far with
the first one being tapo dong tapo dong
was the final result of trying to
replicate the soviet squad rocket the
scud rocket was a series of tactical
ballistic missiles so initially there
were fears that north korea could use
tapo dong as a surface to surface
missile
but the u.s defense intelligence agency
would later suggest that tapo dong was
simply a test bed
anyway in august of 1998 north korea
launched tapo dong 1.
north korean media reported that tapo
dong 1 reached orbit within 5 minutes
after launch and that they had
successfully launched their first
satellite
but western scientists disagree with
this report
according to their observations
tepodong1 was launched and it did reach
an altitude of 200 kilometers however
they suspect that the third stage failed
to ignite as the satellite never
actually reached orbit
based on where the third stage landed
scientists estimate that table dawn
could reach up to 5 900 kilometers if
the mission was successful
and that brings us into their second
attempt with tabo dong
north korea launched apo dong 2 in july
of 2006 nearly eight years after table
dong won
unfortunately there is absolutely no
footage or images relating to this
mission
but the us department of defense did
confirm that the launch did in fact take
place there is not too much to discuss
though as the missile apparently failed
just 40 seconds after launch though it
doesn't seem like the reliability of the
missile was improved observers speculate
that the missile was much more powerful
it's estimated that each stage of the
missile could have a burn time of about
100 seconds which translates to a total
burn time of 5-6 minutes
with a bit of tweaks this could allow
for up to 9000 kilometers of range with
a payload capacity of up to 500
kilograms unfortunately for north korea
though this would never materialize and
they would move on to a new series of
rockets called inha
inha which means galaxy was basically a
frankenstein rocket that incorporated
elements from a few different rockets
the first stage of vinha uses four
nodong motors which are simply enlarged
versions of scud motors
originally the second stage was thought
to be based on the soviet ssn6 missile
but now the general consensus is that
the second stage is also based on the
skud rocket
as for the third and fourth stages these
seem to be identical to the iranian
saphir rockets second stage
so once again it doesn't seem like north
korea added much themselves when
designing the inhale rocket as it's just
a combination of scud and saphir
despite this the inhale rocket would
stir up quite a bit of controversy you
see according to the united nations
security council resolution 1718 north
korea was prohibited from testing
ballistic missiles and as you might have
guessed inhale was a ballistic missile
the us south korea and japan would all
raise red flags at this launch would
violate the agreement
even russia urged north korea to cancel
the planned launch
nonetheless north korea would go ahead
and launch in hatua on april 5th 2009
according to south korea the us northern
command identified at the first stage of
the rocket fell into the sea of japan
and the other stages fell into the
pacific ocean
the missile traveled a rather impressive
3 850 kilometers from the launch site
but the u.s suggests that the third
stage did not actually separate and that
the rocket failed to insert anything
into orbit north korea however still
claims that the rocket was fully
successful and that it put a satellite
into orbit
moving on to their second launch of inha
we have inha iii which took place in
april of 2012. north korea was actually
super confident about this launch and
they even invited observers from eight
different countries to come observe the
launch
but unfortunately for north korea the
launch was a failure
we don't really have any details as to
what exactly happened but it does seem
like north korea was indeed super close
to successfully launching a satellite
just eight months later in december of
2012 another inhale 3 rocket was
launched and this rocket would
successfully launch a satellite into sun
synchronous orbit
though this was a massive milestone for
the north koreans it wasn't all good
news a few days after the launch harvard
astronomer john mcdowell suggested that
though the satellite had reached orbit
it was uncontrollably tumbling in orbit
and the satellite had yet to transmit
anything
following the partially successful
mission the north koreans decided that
it was time to rebrand themselves in
april of 2013 it created a new space
agency called the national aerospace
development administration or nada
i don't think north korea realized that
nada means nothing in spanish
but this coincidence has become a
running joke within the media
anyway moving on to the final and the
most recent launch we have another
in-house relaunch this final launch took
place in february of 2016 and it seems
to be north korea's first fully
successful launch the director of the
scientific research department of nada
confirmed that they had received
photographs from the satellite and thus
far there has been no evidence
suggesting otherwise so north korea does
have the capability to launch small
satellites into orbit as for the
satellites themselves all of the north
korean satellites are part of their
kuang meong song program
china helped north korea develop their
first guang myong song satellite and it
seems like north korea has simply been
improving the chinese design ever since
there have been a total of four
satellites within this program thus far
and the two of them have made it to
orbit with one of them tumbling around
these satellites are simply
communication earth observation
satellites so they're thought to be
completely benign
and that's basically everything we
publicly know about north korea space
agency but that still leaves a question
how dangerous is north korea space
agency
well the center for strategic and
international studies answered just that
according to the csis there are four
major threats that could come from north
korea's rocket slash missile program
with the first being kinetic physical
counter space weapons and more
specifically kinetic asats
asat stands for anti-satellite weapon
and as the name suggests these weapons
are used to destroy the satellites of
other countries thus far north korea has
not tested or announced the development
of any kinetic asa technology moreover
even if they wanted to the csis suggests
that north korea still has several
technological hurdles to cross to
develop an asap so these aren't a threat
moving on to the second category we have
non-kinetic physical counter space
weapons
one example of such a weapon is
launching a nuclear warhead into space
and detonating it some sources suggest
that north korea is actually working on
developing such a device
however there have been no known tests
thus far and the csis doubts that north
korea has enough technology to create
such a weapon in 2013 a chinese military
commentator actually suggested that
north korea does possess this weapon if
this is true then north korea likely got
it from china or russia
but given that north korea can't yet
produce it themselves it's nothing to be
too worried about moving on we have
electronic counter space weapons this
includes technology that can jam gps and
communication signals from satellites
north korea does actually possess this
technology
and they have been using the gma
technology against south korean
satellites since august of 2010.
this actually violates the 1953
armistice agreement but no action has
been taken
after all while jamming signals can be a
nuisance it's not necessarily dangerous
so the international community has more
or less just decided to let north korea
have a blast jamming satellite signals
and finally the last major space threat
from north korea is cyber counter space
weapons
this includes hacking satellites and
space systems from other countries to
extract information or inject corrupt
information the north korean cyber
division is actually quite strong
especially after kim jong-un took over
however western countries seem to still
have the edge when it comes to cyber
warfare
so in conclusion nada is not that
dangerous at this point in time
they're able to jam signals and might be
able to hack a few satellites but in
terms of physical weapons it looks like
we're good to go
do you guys think north korea is a
serious threat comment that down below
also drop a like if you thought this
video explained not a well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one